Hey everybody.
We are joined right now by my friend Neil Williams,
who is currently the lead engineer at Reddit.
Maybe you can tell them a little bit about what your job entails these days.
>> Well, I basically focus first on fixing anything if it's broken, and
otherwise I try to figure out what's, what's the path for the site, like what's
becoming a bottleneck and then try and fix that and make the site fast again.
>> How much traffic does Reddit get these days?
>> Last month we got 2.7 billion page views.
>> That's billion with a b.
And I think when I left Reddit,
which was in 2009, we were nowhere close to that amount of traffic.
I don't remember specifically but I think it's like 10x difference.
I thought Reddit was pretty big when I left, and it was, but
it's a lot bigger now and, and Neil and his team are basically the guys
responsible for keeping the site fast, online and functional.
Which, you know,
over the course of Reddit's history, has that always been the case?
>> We try. >> Yeah, you know, you guys do a very good job.
It's a very impressive job.
So what we're going to do in this,
in this interview here, is I'm going to kind of, I'll,
I'll start off by describing how things worked with Reddit before I left.
And then as we said, traffic increased dramatically.
And Neil will show which parts of the system are gone and what they're doing
now towards the future because a lot of things have, have really changed.
You know when a site grows, grows by huge, huge amounts you,
you have to keep adjusting.
So so the way things were when I left if I recall,
Neil will jump in it's been a few years for me.
The first piece of infrastructure we had was the load balancer, and
we talked about load balancers in unit six.
The one we used was called HA proxy, and
you guys still use HA proxy, is that right?
>> Yes we do. Yeah, it's fast, it never breaks and works for us all the time.
I remember the day I found HA proxy.
It was probably in 2007 and for, god, I mean even after I left for a while I,
is this still the case, do you have, you have multiple HA proxys now, right?
>> Yes. >> Like we were for
a long time, like we had this super scalable architecture and one HA proxy.
We had one machine running one HA proxy and
that handled millions of requests a day.
It was pretty incredible.
So of course, outside of HA proxy is the internet and
all of the Redditors, the unwashed masses of the world, users of the site.
We also used Akamai.
>> Yes.
>> Do you guys still use Akamai?
>> Yes we do.
>> Remember we talked about CDN's, Content Delivery Networks in the,
in the last unit.
Basically these are third-party caches.
So Reddit pays Akamai to ping the site periodically, cache the content and
deliver it to users who, can view cached content.
>> We use that for logged out users only.
Since everybody has their own personal page if they're logged in.
>> But logged out users all see.
>> The same content.
>> The same stuff.
>> So, so logged out users hit Akamai.
And logged in users who have custom content, you know their username,
their votes, all that stuff come in via the internet, and hit HA proxy directly.